- Speaking of new music,
so one of your new songs, Joanna,
it kind of pushes against the media a bit.
It's like, could you talk
about that song a little bit?
- Absolutely, yeah.
So my name is Joanna.
That's my real name
and it's just
like fans or, or just people online,
sometimes refer to me as Joanna.
People think they,
they know you
or people think that
they can draw conclusions
and this is less about the media
and more about kind of this cancel culture
that is so prevalent right now.
- Wow and--
- Especially
you know, on social media
and we're just so quick
to write people off.
You know, people need
to be held accountable
for heinous things that,
that's some people I understand, you know,
why there's this quickness to do that,
but when it comes to like saying someone's
peaked or they, they're done,
their career is over
because you haven't seen
them in a few months
or a few years,
- Yeah.
- that's just so ridiculous to me.
So that's kind of what,
what the song is about.
It's like,
everybody's just one moment away from,
you know, redemption or evolution
or being back--
- Or whatever the next chapter is.
- Exactly, like you
can't write anybody off
and I'm, I'm low key a
prime example of that.
So that's the kind of
what the song is about.